le coc des skis une instance de
démocratie participative né de la
volonté notamment de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des citoyens
des associatifs qui émettent des avis
pour les responsables politiques sur
tout un ensemble de sujets vous allez le
voir on va se pencher sur ce travail
avec yb long de 100 bonsoir c'est le
président du coc des skis père moïse
liliane jakes bonsoir à vous deux vous
êtes des membres aujourd'hui justement
de ce côté ce qui est c'est tout récent
vous venez juste de le rejoindre vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi avoir
décidé de vous impliquer de cette
manière tout d'abord j'ai fait une
petite présentation sommaire sur les
émissions du collet ce qui est ce que je
me trompe
il ya un petit peu plus à lui tout à
fait exact peu détaillé un petit peu si
vous voulez hein
donc ne nous intéressons à priori de
prendre potentiellement l'ensemble des
sujets sur lequel les élus ont des
décisions à prendre
alors ça touche à l'aménagement du
territoire aux transports au sujet de
vie quotidienne comme comme la culture
comme la santé comme la vie associative
comme les jeunes ou aussi toute activité
économique du territoire et au-delà du
territoire
nous avons nous intéressons aussi à
l'opération d'intérêt national de paris
saclay depuis 25 ans et de façon très
active ainsi qu'à tous les débats
régionaux puis par ailleurs à travers la
la coordination nationale des conseils
de développement nous nous intéressons
aussi au projet de loi par exemple sur
l'acte iii de la décentralisation comme
on dit et notamment ne nous intéressons
à ce que la loi reconnaisse les conseils
de développement de façon un petit peu
plus affirmé que la loi actuelle ce sont
des citoyens des acteurs de la vie au
quotidien qui participe justement ce
côté ce qu'est à ce conseil pourquoi
avoir décidé de le rejoindre justement
vous avez déjà reçus sur ce plateau pour
autre chose plutôt pour un travail
d'historien ils ont gagné sur la commune
de guyancourt votre commune là
aujourd'hui c'est une autre casquette
pour je m'implique beaucoup dans la vie
associative déjà dans la commune de
guyancourt et g
envie de participer davantage un certain
nombre de projets et je pense qu'au sein
du code skis je pourrais comment mettre
à profit mon potentiel pour apporter
comment un certain travail utile en ce
qui concerne la vie quotidienne des
saint quentinois et est d'aider à faire
progresser les projets mois ils vont
aussi vous avez rejoint le colistier et
comme les autres membres vous avez été
désigné puisque c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne par des responsables
politiques de l'agglomération de saint
quentin c'est la communauté de
l'agglomération qui désigne les membres
d'écho d'esquisser la communauté
d'agglomération donc le président de la
communauté d'agglomération et les maires
à peu près un tiers désigné par les
maires et un tiers de membres désignés
par la commune de l'agglomération
pour faire simple pourquoi avoir décidé
de rejoindre le connais ce qui en ce qui
vous concerne
c'est une vraiment une démarche très
très personnel lire mon activité
professionnelle lorsque j'ai pris ma
retraite maintenant il y à il ya deux
ans à peu près j'ai souhaité pouvoir
apporter à la collectivité
mamie les connaissances que j'ai pu
avoir tout au long de cette de ma vie
professionnelle vous travaillez dans
calvi jetterai un oeil dans
l'aménagement et dans les transports de
voyageurs en particulier dans le
transport de voyageurs pendant plus de
20 ans et donc je souhaitais faire
profiter de cette expérience la
collectivité et en particulier ce sont
des activités à caractère intercommunal
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
recherché une instance et je dois dire
que ça a été assez complexe parce que je
ne connaissais pas le cas des skis j'ai
mis beaucoup de temps à le trouver
donc c'est une démarche vraiment
personnel qui m'a conduit à rentrer qu
est ce qui vous vouliez travailler sur
les dossiers du publié au transport d
une manière générale les un dossier dont
on va forcément beaucoup parler dans les
prochaines semaines c'est le dossier du
grand paris express puisque le
gouvernement doit rendre ses arbitrages
normalement le 15 février alors on va
effectivement avoir l'occasion de
reparler sur le plateau mais c'est un
dossier que vous avez suivi
oui tout à fait c'est un souci que nous
que nous suivons que le codis qui suit
et où j'ai participé aux deux travaux
du codis qui sûr c'est un bon exemple de
dossier sur lequel nous travaillons
conjointement avec les autres conseils
de développement franciliens en son
temps lors du moment du grand débat sur
le grand paris nous avions fait un
cahier d'acteur commun avec l'ensemble
des conseils de développement
franciliens là tout récemment nous avons
émis un avis sur la priorité à donner à
la ligne verte du métro du grand paris
puisque c'est comme ça qu'elle s'appelle
de passer par saint quentin en yvelines
nous avoir sur sa conjointement avec
notre homologue du plateau de saclay
afin de la communauté d'agglo du plateau
de saclay et avec des assauts des
grandes associations de d'entreprise
tant du côté de l'essonne que des
yvelines c'est un petit peu la
particularité de notre de notre démarche
aujourd'hui le codis qui n'a pour autant
pas de poids pour se faire entendre
c'est purement consultatif nous avons
pas c'est uniquement consultatif nous
avons le poids liée à la qualité de
l'eau vers l'humour on est à la qualité
des chants de frustrant pour autant non
façon quand même si peur vous posant la
question mais c'est pas un peu frustrant
donc de travailler au quotidien
force de proposition voilà c'est cela et
puis en fait nous avons l'occasion
directement de discuter d'échanger avec
les élus de façon très très suivie
que ce soit de façon formelle ou
informelle et donc on a le temps
d'échanger les arguments et puis donc de
participer en quelque sorte à
l'élaboration de la déposition qui ceux
qui se définissent sur la sur la
communauté d'agglomération dans son
ensemble à ses différents conseils de
développement sont trop nombreux à
travers la france puisqu'en fait il
remonte à 1999 c'était la loi voynet qui
les avait mis en place 25 juin 1999
c'était le principe d'un partenariat
entre les élus les milieux
socioprofessionnels les associatifs
également et création donc de ses
conseils de développement dont le code
est ce qu'ils les différents conseils
qui vont se réunir aussi à nantes
vous allez y participer c'est 13 14
février c'est oui c'est après demain
donc et c'est joli et vendredi donc
cette semaine ce sont des rencontres qui
sont 14 février je me suis trompé d'un
jour n'est qu'en février
ne partez pas tout oui effectivement
j'ai encore le temps pour de travail de
bâtir
donc elle se déroule annuellement cette
année c'est sur le thème de la
démocratie participative de l'institut
des l'intitulé c'est au tour du citoyen
et participations continuer à fabriquer
du comme commun voilà l'un portant des
projets de territoire c'est qu'ils
soient partagées c'est comme ça qu'ils
sont les plus les mieux acceptées et qui
génère delà de la mobilisation de la
part des de la part des citoyens
donc il ya typiquement une centaine de
conseil de développement d'après
l'expérience des autres années une
centaine même puisqu'ils sont présents
ça fait quatre cents personnes dont
c'est un événement qui est quand même
assez assez important on a quelques
sombres aux orateurs par rapport aux
autres de conseils celui de saint
quentin en yvelines
on conseille à l'important qui a pris
son rythme de croisière avec tout
journaliste nouvelles personnes qui
veulent le rejoindre
nous sommes une agglomération moyenne et
nous sommes un conseil développement
très actif d'ailleurs nous jouent un
rôle très actif puisque je suis membre
du bureau de la coordination nationale
dont ces développements puis c'est nous
qui anime la coordination régionale
constitue vraiment parmi les conseils
conseil actif
et ça nous permet d'échanger avec les
autres conseils de partager des
expériences de bénéficier un petit peu
leur expérience dans des domaines par
exemple comme les plans d'urbanisme
inter interurbains et les schémas de
cohérence territoriale comme on dit
d'autres conseils ont déjà travaillé
dessus nous nous allons commencer donc
les échanges entre conseils sont très
importants et ces échanges entre conseil
14 15 février du côté de nantes
merci à tous les trois nous avoir
rejoints merci d'une petite précision
vous a pas entendu vos dossiers
prioritaires
si j'ai posé la question je suis en deux
commissions une qui est la vie
associative et la deuxième commission
c'est le parcours de vie c'est-à-dire du
plus jeune âge jusqu'à la fin de vie
merci donc à tous les trois et bon
courage pour la suite de vos travaux le
codé ce qui poursuit son action on reste
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines justement
mais on va aller du côté de l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin ambiance un
peu surprenante aujourd'hui si vous
étiez aux abords de l'université notre
nom de la faculté de médecine
regardez
défilé des étudiants de la faculté de
médecine pour mardi gras ce doux ces
moments comme chaque année les étudiants
se sont déguisés et ont arpenté les rues
de saint quentin en yvelines banane
singer princesse chacun est libre de
s'habiller comme ils le souhaitent
une seule action obligatoire faire
entendre sa voix en chantant le carnaval
de médecine un rendez vous immanquable
pour ces étudiants chez nous c'est une
tradition
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait chaque
année c'est vraiment sympa on est tous
divisés il ya vraiment une bonne
ambiance
murray
les étudiants de première et deuxième
année de médecine n'ont pas hésité à
rentrer dans les salles pour suspendre
les cours des autres filières une
journée de bonne humeur dont qui permet
de faire oublier la pression d'affaires
on a tellement de pression ça fait du
bien un jour dans l'année de n'oublier
toute la sélection tout ça et passer un
bon moment quoi important décompresser
on travaille tellement qu'il ya des
moments forcément et puis c'est bien
c'est enfin c'est une histoire de tak
après tout on ne se connaît bien donc ça
sur sa gamme un carnaval qui a entraîné
des perturbations dans le déroulé des
coûts certains professeurs et ont choisi
de quitter leurs amphis à la vue des
étudiants déguisés